thank you very much for the introduction
i hope you can hear me
my voice is not the best anymore don't
worry i'm not sick but i was teaching in
person all week again for the first time
in a long time
so i'm also very happy to be in a on a
really in-person event again it's also
one of the first
for me
so um geospatial analysis for the smart
city is a topic that
how much time do i have two hours three
hours now 15 minutes so i try
to be as quickly as possible you all
know data and you probably don't know
that more than 80 percent of all data
has a geospatial component
so there is a wear there is a what and
there is a when in many many data sets
and as soon as there is a wear in there
we talk about geospatial data
so um what's geospatial data there are
actually three major points the first is
it's multi-dimensional minimum two
coordinates x y
many data sets have a third one
and there is one
thing about geospatial data it can be
really huge
for example we have a open data set of
switzerland orthophotos they are taken
by plane it's 10 10 centimeters per
pixel over the whole country
that's about 12 terabytes um or 8
billion of these
and if you would stack them actually if
you it's it's it's about 9 centimeters
so if you take this 9 billion floppy
disks you can go to the moon and back
from the distance just to have a small
country like switzerland
and um yeah that's that's a real
challenge to to process such data set
um
yeah and then the other surprising thing
is the earth is not flat even if you
hurt the contrary sometimes
we have to project the data and there
are some challenges with that too
basically we have two kinds of data the
first is the easy one it's raster data
and the second one is vector data you
all know that i don't really have to
explain that but i'm i'm still doing it
just to show you
um the importance of that because if you
process raster data it's really easy so
you can just for example count the
pixels here
um you have
of course you don't have um what's
what's this six by six pixels that's a
little bit small and usually you have
many million by many million so you can
just count the certain
the callers for example and you see okay
30 percent is is a like for example
that's really easy with that
on the other hand if you uh the formats
maybe you all know that it's jpeg png
and tiff however there is an additional
component together you need the
geospatial
location information so there is a fine
projection along with the data so for
every pixel you know the exact location
and for example in tiff and there is a
is a header and in this header all this
information is inside with jpeg and png
it's an additional file um specifying
that
so um vector representations are much
better if you want to have detailed
lines for example and
for there there are some
formats some famous formats like
shapefile
geojson or geopackage and and many many
more
so if you if you download them you you
know what it is
there are
millions of data sets available for free
and some commercially i just put a
couple here some some links actually the
slides are on github i will provide a
link at the end
so um yeah
i looked up there is a geoportal
mannheim so there is actually some
geospatial data available there are some
orthophotos
you have to register there it seems and
then you can actually download the data
over a server there so it seems to be
available too i'm not i didn't see the
details the license detail have to admit
but i think it's possible to get access
there
and more and more countries go open data
so um that's a good thing
however um for today i don't want to use
this data we have another very very
great data set um you probably heard of
that
it's called openstreetmap you can go to
openstreetmap.org
and you will see this one i made a
screenshot of mannheim
at a certain zoom level you can zoom in
the interesting thing or interesting
fact about openstreetmap is it's it's
created by users so everyone can map
everyone can collect things you can go
outside you can take your tracking
device your mobile phone for example
with
gps tracks and then you can you can edit
that and add new things you can say okay
here is a shop here is
whatever and you can really um
contribute to this map
and there are millions of people
contributing nowadays we have the whole
planet um from
from germany up to north korea for
example everything is is mapped um
and it's it's really amazing um
there are some countries i mentioned
north korea because it's not easy to get
maps there and
thanks to such
contributions we have a real cool map of
the whole planet
so
this is the map of course that
may i ask who have you already used
openstreetmap
well quite quite a few people that's
great not not all
who used google maps
okay that's that's the
so you you like um you actually like
giving free data to google that's okay
me too i use
i use google maps too so
that's great but the map is only one
part the other thing that's hidden
actually that's the data we have a huge
amount of data here for example
you could
you could you could get all gas stations
of a certain country and count them so
it could count how many gas stations are
mapped in old germany you could count
that and then you get the results so you
can do you can do things
and there is a really nice
python module it's called osm nx it's
it's python it's called python for
street networks
and it's a module to retrieve model
analyze visualize street networks and
other geospatial data from openstreetmap
it actually gets the data online and you
can do some cool stuff with it so i put
two links there you can install it over
condom
probably pip2 but i'm
i'm not really often using pip nowadays
so
i'm not doing a live presentation i
could i could show it live i will
provide you the the jupiter notebook of
everything i show now but due to time
constraints i'm already eight minutes in
of my 15 minutes
i just show slides so the first thing i
import some
modules i'm not going into all of them
one is volume volume is a is for mapping
i will show some screenshots um after
and of course the most important the osm
nx and the network x library and
i'm sure all of you most of you know
pandas
and there is a alternative called
geopandas
and geopandas is basically pandas with a
with an additional component with
additional geometry so it's just it's
basically the same but you can do some
some more things i'm not going really
into geopandas today the time is too
short
so what we can do we can specify a place
for example mannheim germany i'm sure
there are other mannheims on the planet
so you have to specify the country of
course
and then
actually there are some countries with
multiple cities with the same name then
you have to add a district for example
new york
or something new york new york usa
so it's it's it's pretty clear
so the state uh you can do that too but
the simplest here is manheim germany and
then you just call ox the graph from
place and then you can specify the
network type there are some network
types available for example the drive or
bike with bike paths if you want to know
where you can bike there
and you can also download all then you
get all i just did the drive so i
came here by taxi i wanted to see if
this this route is correct from if the
taxi driver does just the fastest route
which he didn't but we can talk about
that later
so that's what what um what it looks
like if i plot it there is a function
plot chlorograph and then you see the
street network of mannheim
you i think most of you are from manheim
so sorry i'm more familiar with the city
so i think it looks
correct i guess
you can export it as a shape file or
other format
and that's quite easy save graph a shape
file for example and then you can store
it and you can open it with a with a
cheese software for example or or
whatever software you want to use but
i'm not going to that so what i want to
have is our nodes and straights the
nodes are the insection intersection
points and the streets are obviously the
streets of the network and there are 14
414
441 streets i can't say in mannheim i
have to say in the data set of open
street map representing manheim so there
are probably some small streets not yet
in
open street map so that's what you have
to do and map everything missing
and if i um displayed at geopanda's data
frame it looks like this at least the
first three
entries of the
graph network i can do some some
simple analysis showing what kind of
street was three types are
there and
the most street types are residential
and so that's that's um
actually it's normal most cities are
like this in the distribution
i can then plot this on volume with a
couple lines of code volume
uses certain
map tiles in the background so you can
it's actually two or three lines of code
you have a map in jupiter so it's a
quite cool thing and i recommend opening
my
notebook so you can see it in action
so i can plot i can convert the street
network to a json file and then display
it that's yellow and that's the street
network we saw before
so let's geo code some two positions
there um that there is a ox geocode
function which which returns um
exact position in gps coordinates or in
wgs 84 coordinates so for example i take
the mannheim hybrid in mannheim germany
i
geocode it and i get this position back
i checked it it's correct
and then
this building here i enter julius hatred
ins and even the post lightsail postcode
and
manheim germany and i get the position
of this building
somewhere
in this building and um that worked
actually
so i um plot my i create a map again
and um i make some markers you can see
that in the code how it's actually done
so i at the train station and here the
muffy next building so we have two two
buildings great
so the next step is let's let's find
them the shortest path which is not that
easy
in this situation you know that if you
this bike i think it's easier but
if you use the car from the um
hove to here you have to make this
detour
so let's see if this works
so there are some
functions like get nearest node and get
nearest um and get shortest paths
and i get the nearest node of my
position that's just you have to imagine
i get the next intersection closest to
this gps position
and then i calculate the shortest path
and it looks like this but don't be
fooled by by this graph because it's
it's not along the street it's just a
line along the node so from node to node
now to note it's not it's not matching
so don't be surprised if it doesn't
match the streets it's just a node
connection and um actually the taxi
driver i don't know if you can actually
drive here
here is the whole school i think is the
correct somewhere here and i'm not sure
if this is possible i know the taxi
driver he he went down here and up here
so
did he cheat me
or is it correct
it's unfortunately correct because all
the other streets are closed they're
closed okay so that's a job for for um
people here you have to correct the data
set in openstreetmap and close them and
then next time this will be perfect
so i'm running out of time but does this
doesn't matter i'm ah it's it's a couple
of more slides so
another thing you can do um is
retrieving building footprints so from
every building in
in every city or every place you can get
the footprints with calling geometries
from place you can have some tags for
example building you can also have some
other um
things there but the most important
geometry in in the open sweep map data
set or buildings
so you can plot it it looks like that
so you have really all building
footprints because there's really some
people really map this and they
it's it's available of nearly every city
worldwide it's really a great stuff and
you can do some queries again you can
for example for all buildings or city
at least the footprints you can search
for museums
and then you get from for each museum
you get the polygon so um it's not
complete um there are still some museums
in manheim you could map
or tag at least i think the building is
in there it's just not tagged correctly
and i also did another place there is a
function poise from place where you
actually you don't get the the building
footprint you just get the
the tag museum it's tourism museum
and if i do that i get a couple more
museums here it's probably not complete
i would guess so that's again a job for
you to to map this and to make this data
set as complete as possible and now with
about one minute too much i'm coming to
an end
so thank you very much uh for interest
and
the um the slides or and and the
notebook is located here
on github it's
open source of course mit license you
can do what you want with it thank you